deku's Quirk was stolen by shigaraki if
you've been following the latest twists
in the mha manga then you know that
shigaraki managed to steal one of deku's
quirks he placed his hand on deku's face
long enough to use the Quirk all for one
to steal danger sense which once
belonged to the fourth user of one
forall shinomori not only did shigaraki
steal the Quirk but he is already using
it against Deku in battle thankfully
Deku didn't get weaker after losing
danger sense because he still has one
for all itself so he still has all the
power that the quk has accumulated over
the past nine Generations but shigaraki
has now proven that he does have enough
willpower to steal one for all's Quirk
factors which is something that no one
else was ever able to do one more touch
from shigaraki and Deku could lose
another Quirk or even one for all itself
to stay up to date with all the latest
twists in mha subscribe to anime uproar
right now